Papa ich glaube die Ziege hat auch ein
bisschen Mayonnaise gemacht
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
heute gibt es ein Club Sandwich fürs
Club Sandwich gibt es eigentlich kein
bestimmtes Rezept denn jeder macht sein
Sandwich wie er möchte und ihr könnt
jetzt dafür entweder Toastbrot verwenden
oder Brot was sie zu Hause habt oder ihr
backt euch gerne ein Brot ich habe mir
jetzt gedacht ich backe jetzt einfach
ein Brot aus unserer Brot Nummer zwei
Mischung ist nämlich ein Dinkelbrot und
dafür verwende ich einfach die
Brotmischung brauche etwas Hilfe und
Wasser aber das steht auch alles auf der
Packung aber wie gesagt dürft ihr auch
ganz gerne ein fertiges Brot verwenden
denn es geht ja im Prinzip nicht ums
Brot sondern um die Füllung und wie wir
das Sandwich gleich füllen werden also
ich bereite daraus einfach eine Hefeteig
zu und lass ihn aufgehen und werde in
der Zwischenzeit dann die Füllung und
das Sandwich innere vorbereiten
[Musik]
und den Hefeteig knete ich jetzt einfach
für zehn Minuten gebe schon ein bisschen
Hitze drauf also ungefähr so 30 Grad
dann geht er gleich schneller
jetzt der Hefeteig wird aufgegangen und
ich fette jetzt meine Backmatte ein
bisschen und die Hände denn es kann sein
dass der Teig noch ein bisschen klebt
aber ich will jetzt nicht zusätzliches
Mehl dazugeben
[Musik]
habe ich schon mal erwähnt wie sehr ich
Hefeteige Liebe
nein
ich liebe Hefeteige sehr
einfach immer schön
und ich möchte jetzt die Form eines
toastbrots deswegen nehme ich unsere
Baba Backform und Fette die
schön mit backtrennspray überall
auch den Deckel
und ich weiß jetzt nicht
ob ein Brot
vieles für die eine Form
aber ich probiere es mal
und zwar schön von außen nach innen so
dass die Oberfläche ein bisschen
gestritzt wird
ich gucke jetzt mal ob ich ein Brot
draus mache oder zwei
ich mache ein Brot draus
ja
ich nehme
alles das Brot Nummer zwei und Brot
Nummer zwei geht so krass auf
ist doch ein bisschen Mehl aus
was tue ich jetzt
noch mal reinlegen zum Gucken
das geht schon krass auch Brot Nummer 2
ich nehme von hier zum Drittel weg
ich nehme jetzt zwei Drittel des Teiges
und füllen die barberform weil ich
einfach ein perfektes Kastenbrot will
und so formt ihr einfach von außen nach
innen
die Oberfläche schön
und dann legt das hier rein
jetzt ist gerade bis zur Hälfte gefüllt
und das ist jetzt super
das wird der Hammer
das denke ich jetzt ab
und werde es dann kurz etwa 10 Minuten
hier noch mal stehen lassen und aufgehen
lassen und dann kommt es aber in den
kalten Backofen ich halte es dann den
Ofen vor und dann kann sie mich im Ofen
noch mal schön aufgehen und du wir
schalten kleines Mini Brot
und das Brot backe ich dann bei 200 Grad
also so hält sich den Ofen dann noch vor
und nehme dann nach etwa 30 Minuten den
Deckel runter und backst dann noch mal
etwa 10 Minuten weiter und dann kann ich
jetzt in der Zwischenzeit kurz die
Füllung zu machen okay
klappt Sandwich können wir mal kurz
drüber reden wie schön dieses Brot
geworden ist
wonderful es ist wunder wunderschön und
ich liebe dieses Dinkelbrot Geller
Sandwich
hervorragend denn ich habe jetzt hier
schon mal die Zutaten die zeige ich euch
mal zum einen oh warte mal ich lese euch
das mal vor was in den Club Sandwich
reingehört Mädels okay denn da gibt es
kein bestimmtes Rezept dafür sondern
es ist so dass es jeder anders macht
aber lesen wir doch mal es kommt eine
dünne Scheibe Schinken oder Speck auf
ein quadratisches Stück Brot was
getoastet oder nicht getoastet ist wir
haben hier Puten Schinken nee Puten
Bacon ist das putenbecken ähm darauf
kommen
ein paar Gewürzgurken
darauf kommt etwas gegrilltes Hähnchen
oder Pute davon kommt ein Teelöffel voll
Mayonnaise
davon kommt noch mal ein Toast und
stammt die zwei zusammendrücken und
große Dreiecke schneiden und das macht
jeder anders bei den meisten kommt noch
Salat Tomate und Gurke drauf und Käse
und es steht auch dass ein New York Club
Sandwich aus drei Schichten Brot besteht
okay
Avocado also das erste was wir jetzt
hier tun werden ist ich werde das
Hähnchen äh Brustfilet wow ich so viel
Englisch gelesen und deswegen fahren wir
durcheinander gehen Hähnchenbrustfilet
und den
putenbecken werde ich jetzt hier erstmal
anbraten und was ihr tun könnt wir
können ja dazu noch so ein paar
Kartoffeln aus dem Ofen essen oder macht
ihr so ein bisschen kartoffelwedges dazu
ich habe da schon Kartoffeln gewaschen
und wenn da so kleine Stücke noch dran
sind tut dir einfach sauber machen und
dann schön schneiden
alles richtig gemacht
ich muss noch was Umpflanzen ja
[Musik]
ab dem 17 februar ist Sally bei Let's
Dance wer cool wenn ihr einschaltet und
sind vielleicht unterstützt
[Musik]
das Hähnchenfleisch das wird jetzt hier
schön angebraten von beiden Seiten und
wirklich darauf achten das ist
durchbraten dann Hähnchen und Geflügel
aller Art sollte man nicht roh oder auch
nicht Medium oder sonst wie verzehren
wirklich gut durchbraten und ich habe
hier auch diesen putenspeck den werde
ich ja auch gleich braten und dann kann
ich eigentlich die Zwischenzeit nutzen
um die Gurken und die Tomaten noch rein
zu schneiden
am besten die einzelnen Scheiben so hin
schau mal dann werden die Kartoffeln
schön knusprig wie so eine große Blume
[Musik]
okay die Kartoffeln sind jetzt gleich
fertig bzw sie sind schon fertig
Samira Eller und Moritz sind auch gleich
da jetzt schneiden wir erstmal das Brot
auf
das sieht perfekt aus
okay dann belegen wir jetzt mal das
Sandwich also hier die erste Scheibe
Brot
dann gebe ich da ein bisschen Mayonnaise
drauf
dann haben wir hier das Fleisch
ich glaube deshalb wäre ich einfach mal
so
darauf
etwas Salat
Tomaten wie sieht's aus cool und lecker
saure Gurken
einfach noch ein zweites drauf so
richtig New York Style machen New York
Style
also dann noch mal Mayonnaise
dann unser Puten bacon
Käse
nee vor dem Käse noch mal Fleisch dann
aufs Brot Nummer Mayonnaise ich glaube
das ist richtig New York Style
und noch mal gut
mögt ihr doch
habe ich was vergessen
[Musik]
so das wäre jetzt unser New York Club
Sandwich made in waghäusle oder
[Musik]
ist gut gell
ja das ist New York Style also ich muss
sagen so normalerweise einfach zwei
Scheiben
schwäbisches Teil gereicht Butter mit
Brot fertig
nee wir machen ich zeig's euch auch im
Rezept als
normales Sandwich ich glaube das wird
jetzt werden Sie im Restaurant
angerichtet wurde
diese Baumscheiben zum präsentieren
unsere Holzbretter
bei Yvonne
Yvonne so richtig schön einen schönen
Teller und dann holen wir noch Ketchup
aus dem Kühlschrank
Ella kriegt Gürkchen genau
[Musik]
so war das dann ich glaube wir müssen
Restaurant aufmachen dann würden sie das
so machen ja dann
würde man
hast du Ketchup gefunden
ich hätte auch schon meine Restaurant
Mitarbeiter rechts im Kühlschrank
sammeln genau
[Musik]
okay ich glaube so geht es auch auf dem
Restaurant auch zu so der Rente eine
Rente andere okay jetzt wartet kurz hier
noch die Kartoffeln
so würde es doch im Restaurant angeboten
werden oder macht mir sehr schön Foto
oder ihr dürft das jetzt probieren ich
habe jetzt leider keinen Schälchen für
ach ja
die meisten Menschen auch noch kennt ihr
das vielleicht noch
ich glaube das kennt jeder Deutsche
Kenntnis Fehler Gewürze
so
hier so wird es jetzt im Restaurant
angeboten werden oder was denkt ihr
würde ich auch Geld bezahlen ja
unseren Spießen weil man dann direkt das
Messer benutzen kann zum durchschneiden
oh wow guckt euch das mal an
was würdest im Restaurant Kurs was meint
9 Euro schon ja nie mehr Kartoffeln
dabei und Brot und das ist schon ich
würde schon so 18 Euro dann
Euro jetzt ehrlich sind Burger
gibt es doch diese diese Dings Burger
diese selbstgemachten also mit sowas
habe ich jetzt verglichen am Flughafen
vielleicht so 12 12 Euro vielleicht
der erste Schritt
eure Kartoffel probieren
[Musik]
ja tolle Kartoffeln gemacht
und das Brot ist selbstgemacht mit
unserem Dinkelbrot 2 Hamburg
[Musik]
soll man den Typ da an der Scheibe
reinlassen
der guckt da rein als hätte Hunger
du sahst so hungrig aus an der Scheibe
oh mein Gott vor lauter Dingen ich muss
mal ehrlich
das da ist das Brot nur Butter drauf
macht gell
und deswegen habe ich es auch selber
gebacken ich finde klar ihr könnt
wirklich jetzt hergehen Sandwich Brot
toastbroten anderes Brot nehmen aber
dieses Dinkelbrot ist es so gut es
schmeckt so gut richtig fluffig das ist
guck mal das ist so
so schön
[Musik]
Holland genau so ist das also probiert
unser klapp-sandwich gerne mal aus klapp
Sandwiches Style und ich wünsche euch
viel Spaß beim Nachmachen bis zum
nächsten Mal tschüss
[Musik]